I did what I miss okay so they just  drove down the field third and long in  the red zone  all right play back  we got a player where's the remote jeez  I can't believe we missed it  but here's a replay oh oh oh wait  there's a remote dude what's going on  with the remote dude just go up to the  TV and switch it again oh my gosh this  is so stupid  what's wrong with your TV what is this  white all right you know what we're  going to Joyce place we're gonna watch  the game of joeys place all right let's  go to Joey's if you later Jenny see you  Joe see you next week  there's their mouths  you  thanks for watching remote threat head  on over to Kendall zebediah channel for  some amazing sketch comedy sketches and  if you liked the video remember to like  this video and subscribe for a awesome  or short film every other week and we'll  see you in the next one  assuming we both survive oh geez I  wonder what could happen Oh